welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and our infinity Saga rewatch just
turned up one of the biggest clues yet
for a forgotten loosen'd in the
background of them's new films a detail
exposed in avengers endgame that blend
cross-reference with Easter eggs and
guardians of the galaxy and Thor
Ragnarok might reveal the whole plot of
Thor 4 toward love and thunder or even
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 movies
that are still happening just further
away to me talk folks we have been
looking at shocking evidence of a Thanos
genocide well another one because
there's been a lot this whole time this
whole time a slaughter of an entire race
of beings or like half of them that will
come back to haunt many of these
characters okay so we got some clues in
recent weeks about Thor for guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 Valkyrie actress Tessa
Thompson confirmed that Christian Bale
will be playing the villain of Thor love
and thunder which based on the alien
descriptions of the character and the
fact that an actor like Christian Bale
is definitely gonna have his iconic
beautiful face in there we have assumed
will be Gore to God butcher other recent
videos we've made have explained how
Gore's a sword is all black the necro
sword a sword that was used to sever the
head of nowhere by the Clint our
symbiote deity of null so to condense
all that nerd [ __ ] for you the weapon
Thor's villain uses in the next movie
maybe the thing that created one of the
most important locations of the
guardians movies in the MCU at Lords
also in recent weeks Vin Diesel confirm
that there would be a crossover of
guardians of the galaxy characters in
Thor love and thunder and we speculated
that at the very least that crossover
will be GGI voiceover characters like
groot obviously and rocket assuming this
to be true
what could this rocket and Groot subplot
in Thor 4 be and the story already dense
with the drama of gore the god butcher
we think depowering the god of thunder
so that Jane Foster has to take up the
helm how could rock itand group possibly
tie into that
well recent reexaminations of endgame
just turned up a big clue during the
time ice the 2014 timeline nebula and
Gomorrah were in the midst of a battle
on an alien world and the official
screenplay for Avengers endgame was
released a few months back confirming
that this planet was the korbinites home
world and at these combatants were the
korbinites soldiers in carbonite
rifleman korbinites are the race of beta
ray bill the fan-favorite character who
temporarily takes on the title of thor
and mule near in the comics this easter
egg ties in with two other major Easter
eggs and past MCU films first in the
first guardians of the galaxy when Peter
danced his way over to the Morag temple
to recover the power stone orb he passed
and slapped a korbinite skeleton this
dead korbinite was desecrated
concurrently with the war on the
korbinite homeworld by Thanos his forces
so how long was that dead korbinite
sitting on Morag for well on earth a
human corpse when exposed to the
elements and picked apart by scavengers
can be turned into a skeleton in a few
days effect I know not from personal
experience but we have to assume similar
atmospheric conditions on Morag to those
of earth people appear to be breathing
oxygen there may be some heightened
humidity levels since Morag used to be
covered by oceans and puddles are still
around everywhere and there are
definitely some scavengers hopping
around though or Loney rat creatures and
of course this idiot scavenger who plugs
into his mommy's playlist in a hostile
environment
so this korbinite could have fled corbin
during Thanos's invasion wounded hoping
to make it to the Power Stone in order
to save his people he died too soon the
news of his Flame could have been what
informed Thanos where the Power Stone
was hold on to that as we move on to the
second Easter Egg which appeared in thor
ragnarok of the champions enshrined on
the grandmasters palace of Sekar was
clearly a korbinite Edmund Eve assumed
the head of beta ray bill so combine all
three of these korbinites sightings and
we have evidence of an overlooked
history in the MCU of a korbinite
genocide and diaspora in 2014 Thanos and
his forces targeted Corbin on his
campaign to go planet by planet to wipe
out half of their populations the Battle
of Corbin was a huge game changer for
Thanos because one of those korbinites
fled to the nearby abandoned planet of
Morag to seek the korbinites ultimate
fail-safe weapon the Power Stone but
they failed and Thanos now knew the
location of one of his long sought-after
Infinity stones sending him on his stone
quest resulting in that whole hot potato
action we got in the first Guardians
movie what became of these defeated
korbinites the infinity war an endgame
directors rusa brothers have described a
nose as a Genghis Khan style Conqueror
and other great continental Empire
builders like the Romans their defeated
civilizations were often enslaved for it
out across their known universe and in
some cases transformed into gladiator
warriors exactly the kind of lives that
gladiators of Sekar have and Ragnarok
coorg told Thor that he was enslaved
after a failed rebellion
but didn't print enough pamphlets so
hardly anyone tuned up Hulk ended up on
Sekar after fleeing earth a world that
was hostile to him similarly the
korbinites who was the past champion
beta ray bill could have been a survivor
of Thanos invasion on Corbin in 2014 and
now three years later has become a
warrior alongside Hulk in court but does
Hulk being the reigning champion when
Thor arrived means that bill has been
defeated and dead
well not necessarily he could have just
retired hung up the jersey as a victor
and is now living in retirement on the
planet remember a ragnaroks post-credits
scene implied the people's two car were
rising up in an insurrection removing
the Grandmaster from power this
revolution has been a huge success
yeah odds is I've been a big part of it
can't have a revolution without somebody
to overthrow so you're welcome perhaps
the new ruler in the present de anza car
could be the strongest badass left on
that planet after Hulk left beta ray
bill and that could be the context of
this mystery crossover with rocket and
Groot and Thor for perhaps when Thor
loses in a match to Gore the god butcher
no longer capable of wielding Mjolnir
rocket and Groot head out in search of a
past warrior who could be worthy taking
them to Sekar to find beta ray bill sole
survivor of the once great korbinite
power stone keepers now Vince McMahon of
Marvel's trash pit in exchange for his
help
Groot has to fight in the arena which
might be what Vin Diesel meant by saying
his next Groot form would be alpha Groot
guys Vin Diesel's had to promo my
question to you is assuming all of this
is true who do you want to voice beta
ray bill in the MCU he's probably gonna
be a mocap character like core bright
well given the past association with
fellow New Zealander Taika Waititi Sam
Neill would be my choice only because I
just really want to hear that rich spent
Auckland voice / out from under a Norse
snout as he gazes out upon a whole
planet of brutes
comment down below with your thoughts on
all this and join our watch along to the
Infinity Saga films on discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rockstars follow me on instagram and
twitter at EI vos follow new rockstars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]